millions of Soviet citizens were killed
during Stalin's terror regime the new
gulag Museum in Moscow tells some of
their stories they're the kind of
accounts that aren't welcome in Putin's
Russia because they tarnished the
shining image of Russia's past that
people are so keen to promote least most
fiercely key even my friends young
people are asking why are you doing this
this is about criminals when I hear that
I think they're exactly the kind of
people who need this museum instrument
Lenny does Nate says that Mooji you
won't find Vasily Roedean in this museum
according to his great niece he was
denounced apparently in an act of
revenge Nastya Tarasova says he was
killed in the gulag three months after
his arrest in 1937 photographs and
archival records have helped Nastya
piece together part of his story but she
won't find any personal documents from
her family in the new gulag Museum
doctrine where there's a big memory gap
in my family history until now it's been
filled with stories passed down from
generation to generation but I want the
real documents so I don't drift into
some fantasy world of speculation about
my family Nastya is not alone most of
Stalin's victims were never
rehabilitated the new gulag museum
doesn't do much to change that it's
interactive exhibits do deal with more
recent Soviet history and highlight the
Communist Party's responsibility for the
role of Joseph Stalin as a perpetrator
is not clearly addressed and neither is
that of the repressive Soviet regime
that up to the 1960s sent many of its
citizens to labor camps
but focusing on the Stalin period the
museum doesn't however include the
persecution of dissidents after Stalin's
death
the tragic inheritance of the Soviet
dictator under president Putin's rule
Russian officials have been trying to
downplay Stalin's crimes focusing more
on Stalin's role in the Soviet world
were to victory over Nazi Germany
perhaps it's unrealistic to expect
anything different amid this backdrop of
new Russian patriotism these are times
when once again anyone questioning the
status quo risks being punished